the following episode of FOFA specified
ma it contains some course language some
nudity drug references a sex scene time
treble terrible Batman impersonations at
Charlie Clausen pronounced Clausen
shaped hole and mile course language
foaf up advises that the program is not
suitable for persons under the age of 15
and minors must be accompanied by an
adult guardian or priest this is John
deke speaking
[Music]
to another call
hello and welcome to profile Bob will
Anderson and joining me first time guest
Charlie Clausen now here's the thing
though I have never before I've saved
this until we started doing the podcast
but I have never before had more
requests for somebody to be a guest
Charlie on this show then our guests
today there's yes charlie but question
how are you mate I'm fantastic yeah for
real for real like I mean I think I
think maybe like a lot of people who
listen this podcast must listen to your
podcast and so it feels to me that's
where it comes from like that often what
I get is a like a combination of either
you should have but on your podcast or
you should go on Bert's podcast so I
would love that be on my podcast well I
mean apparently there's at least four or
five people who would also love that so
it's nice to have everything I think I
made my career from podcasting like I
think my podcasting helped my career
exponentially better than TV like I'm
not even doing TV anymore just doing my
podcast and my career has never been
better
why do you think that is because I mean
I love podcasting I've been doing it for
a long time I have like four of them
like it's you know as I like to say I
have an entire imaginary radio station
and people often ask why you know like
all the time you have to put into it all
the effort you have to put into it what
is it about the podcast that I what do
you like about it but B what do you
think the audience like if ever um I
tell you what I like about oh I just
drove driving over here just said this
is what I love about podcasting Pauly
Shore was on Joe Rogan's podcast and he
said he's very sad that he doesn't have
a film career anymore and he's very open
and honest about being on Adam Sandler's
set for his movie and how he wanted to
be the star how he wanted like it was
and I go that's vulnerable like there's
vulnerability that's honesty you know
you'd never see Pauly Shore talk like
that on stage
never never so as a fan of someone's or
not even as a fan when you see someone
share vulnerability or honesty or or
just can't candor like he's like the I
like I liked Ricky Gervais man when I
heard his podcast I loved Ricky Gervais
and I think that on that way like my
stand-ups good but is it I think when
you hear me on a podcast you go oh
that's a little bit of what he does
on stage with a whole lot of other real
stuff that that strangers would never
sit through well yeah but the other
thing is that I mean look there's such
beauty in the complexity of things
because like you know sometimes even
like maybe there'll be something from
this podcast that ends up on stage oh
that's that my entire act is based off
of things I sat on a podcast that people
lost it and I got I mean my I can't even
tell you the people that listen to
podcasts are the coolest fans ever when
I wanted to drogon probably six years
ago five years ago and I told the
Machine story Rogan said you need to
tell the machines story every time you
go onstage and he goes you guys
listening force him to tell that story
shout out the machine until he tells it
because Burt this will change your
career he's like if you just keep
telling it it'll get good so the next
week I was in Columbus this guy sit in
the front row and there's chanting the
machine and I'm going guys I don't tell
it on stage at the time quite honestly I
was a derivative hacky comic and in all
honesty I was doing material that was
some of it was good like you'd find some
nuggets but for the most part I think it
was a lot of this fun boy party comedy
like Dane Cook Nick Swardson nothing
against either their acts but like you
know interchangeable Steve Byrne Bret
Ernst not Sebastian splice fashion at
the time and right the guys that I would
put in a category well Brett some of
those guys transcenders category and
yeah and I don't mean this in a fancy I
don't mean it evokes the sort of guys
that if you went to a comedy night and
they're on they're gonna crush yeah
whatever whatever the night is they will
crush Kirby it was more about crushing
yeah like I was young and I just thought
I want a crotch I was like 37 36 maybe
and uh and I go up and they're chanting
the Machine I knew there's a 12-minute
story did I once I start I have to
commit to I'm not gonna do it I go guys
it's not a face Tory this guy's a
podcast man in the front row and he goes
hey Bert listen we know it's not gonna
be good but you need to do this and I'm
like what [ __ ] fans do you I'm like I
literally was like dude can I find 500
of you right have you everywhere and and
and now when I work a story and now I'm
feel like all I did was tell stories but
when I work a story I hear that guy my
head going it's not going to be good
it's not going to be good but if you
to be a better comic you need to keep
doing it as it sucks the story out right
now that's killing is a ziplining story
with my family the first time I did it
it bombed but I knew I was like if I
just keep doing it it'll it will get
good and now it is crushing and I go I
just hear that my head but by the way I
would have never done that have one
podcasting yes so that's the thing
that's interesting to me so this world
of podcasting how it actually affects
your standup in Reverse because this
journalist who was asked some of these
questions about podcasting one of the
questions they asked me and asking me a
whole bunch of things that I don't
really engage with or think about that
often so it just kind of made me start
to have to think about them and he was
kind of looking at from the perspective
of how has it affected your standup in
regard to people coming to see your
standup which it certainly has like you
know there are people who come out from
the podcast but what I really was like
no it's affected my stand up because
it's reminded me like the things that
people have responded to on this podcast
have been moments of complexity or
moments where you've taken like 12
minutes to tell a story because
sometimes if you tell it in three
minutes you're going to get a
black-and-white one angle on what the
story was about but if you tell it in 12
you get to have the journey of here's
where I was wrong here's where they were
wrong here's where this thing happened
he is where I learnt this you can you
tell you to another comedian often and
they ask the question that an audience
would have asked right and yeah I'm
sorry I mean to a rock you know no feel
free to interrupt that's why I said it's
fine if we're going to not interrupt
those other this realizing this is as
you can you just be in a fight with my
wife that's going around you know that's
how a conversation works you say
something that I say something it
sometimes you say that makes me think of
something and I say it oh my god um I
think podcasting what is is the one
thing I say when it goes how does it
affect it people come to your shows the
number one thing I get said that people
say to me had a show not number one
thing but like number one things will
you do a shot with me but the number one
of the moment ones that I like the best
is hey man thank you for all the free
content and it's just you know it's one
of the things like some guys that start
podcasts and they make it like a billing
service you got to sign up and pay
monthly I go i I think you're missing
the point you know Jon Ronson who wrote
a book so you've been publicly shamed
and he's doing something for audible I
like
audible but it's not in my like my
three-point shooting circumference with
my thumb like I can real quick go what
am I going to listen to on this ride and
just swipe over hit podcast go to go to
the podcast app and go who we got who
got I went oh sure that's cool and then
Polly says all I did Joey Diaz and I got
so high I couldn't finish it I'm like
okay I'll be listening at all right oh
so like I don't know man I I love him I
would say I had a meeting with my agency
and they're like we have a new podcast
guy I know you have a podcast rap but
like we'd be interested if you'd just at
least take the call see if you'd be
interested in leaving so I was like sure
I talked to the guy and I say hey man
just so you know you're talking to a guy
who's really in the podcast so like I
hope that you have more information than
me and he was like I know what I'm doing
and then halfway through he's like I
clearly I don't man I'm sorry right I
know you were legit I'm a legit podcast
fan yeah like that's what I listen to
so what were the podcast that you were
listening to before you started
podcasting Oh Ricky Gervais Joe Rogan
Marc Maron Marc Maron's and I'm not but
Martin Maron when he puts I loved when
he did comics I'm not a big fan of the
band guys yeah I'm with um I don't like
filmmakers I don't want to get these
stars off this [ __ ] podcast yes and
comics are you get comics just find a
hole get mark you you're back playing
the clubs I'm sure you're having awkward
interactions with other comedians again
there all the time I can't get them on
your podcast and sort out there's all
good interaction yes I believe in
tourism you can have people back mark
like I haven't dog Stan hold back like
yeah he's it's been six years that you
had him on right it was and also you
know what it was nice that you had the
president around yeah but maybe to have
a beef with the president and then
getting back on so that you guys have to
sort out where you had your base but in
and marks still like I listen to the one
he did the other day sometimes he has an
act Ron that surprises me and I go oh
this guy's pretty deep
this is I hear Jason Bateman on that was
[ __ ] amazing it was amazing but like
like meirin's Rogen's a Ricky Gervais
I was I was obsessed with this American
life and and those were probably my
quick go twos you know
then anyone that was at the time when if
someone had got a started a podcast I
get into it now that day was a good old
days like that's because that's often
these days when somebody asks you about
the podcast but like what's your podcast
about I was like ah no we're from a time
where it was enough that you had a
podcast it didn't need to be about
something for a while it was just like
there's a new one we'll listen to that
one as well I guess because we ran out
of the other five podcast there was a
moment where they were just trying to
get any MMA fighter in the comedian to
get right I wanted to do is show it
there's this guy Jason mayhem Miller
he's a he is notorious like I like on
the edge of sanity okay and he did this
really long real sports interview on
real sports on HBO
that was bizarre like bizarre and öand
into a podcast with him and just go
because he's an intense guy go heaven
you don't even have to leave your house
all I need you to do is I'm going to
record an intro and then you I'll send
it to you you listen to it and then just
comment and just blow up and then I'll
pretend we shot it together anything you
walk out of the room and I'll just go
well he's gone and we'll do it and but I
never did it
I've had a million I've had a million
great ideas for podcasts that I've
wanted to do I wanted to do I mean one
of the most Steve Renta's Easy's we
thought we thought of it on my podcast
is called hear me that book where
someone's never he doesn't read the book
and someone who has comes in and just
tells him about a book I wanted to do a
bunch but just like just give me what I
need to know if I didn't need to know it
all just run me through it give me the
general vaad my busines Harry Potter is
like the wizard right he was it did he
live in a cupboard just tell me the [ __ ]
I need to know I died what's a
Gryffindor I tried desperately I used to
work for a network called Travel Channel
like seven years for seven years I kept
trying to get them they are owned by
scripts which owns cooking food travel
DIY HDTV all the home-improvement ones I
tried forever to get them to start a
podcast network I was like you have no
idea what you guys have all the stars
right in the home category just start a
pop that absolute things that people and
you can say it now with the big sort of
podcast line
no sort of bigoted commercial radio apps
they're going after those people they're
getting those celebrity chefs they're
getting those sort of celebrity you know
DIY people and they're all you know
Bobbie players yes I'm a big cooking
show fan like a really big cooking show
fan and I'm also like my favorite just
for the record because I just is Tom
Colicchio from Top Chef - you know ever
watched Top Chef I love that show but
also love him but also I love he just
deals out sweet burns on people on
Twitter around politics and it's like
I'm really into it I've become quite a
big fan of his Twitter feed because like
he is not happy with what's happening in
America and his booklet in a really fun
way and then when people get mad because
he's a guy from Top Chef he burned him
in a way that he would kick someone else
Top Chef for burning food it is the best
I love it I gotta talk him out yeah
Bobby Flay so Bobby Bobby play wanted
and I are partying in Houston one in
Dallas one night and he's like we're
doing an event
he's like ham in LA and tomorrow I know
you're in LA and he's like I'm really
interested in podcasts do you mind if I
could come on your podcast I want to see
what it's about I was like sure he was
under the impression that we would be in
some big studio right with like with air
conditioning he came to my house I was
in gym shorts no shirt and I was like
and he was in a suit with a driver and
here like and he was like where do we do
it here I said oh we do it my man cave
we went back and my man came in he was
like and all I have is my eight-six my
two Mike's he's like where's everyone
else like oh this is it Bobby he was
like are you kidding me he's like I can
do this I go no me [ __ ] that's like I
always hear when you hear celebrities go
I won't say the celebrity's name but I
ran into him the other day and I was
like hey I won't have you on my podcast
he's like well I can I do it when my
podcast comes out cuz I'm about to start
a podcast I said sure when's that he
goes well we're almost done signing the
deal so when as soon as the deals closed
we're gonna start a deal with who and he
was like I gotta get you know it's a big
deal to sort of walk out snow when you
just go to like Sam Cooke or goodie
music and just get it a recorder in two
mics and that's it you know I think his
no I gotta get my producers on board you
don't introduce this I was like you know
I mean eventually it would be good to
have one do be nice for someone to keep
track of my SD cards that would be nice
yeah exactly I mean don't get me wrong
we now have a producer he's named Mike
Lee lives in Oregon and we because
Charlie and I often record our shows
from different countries but we just
record them like we both just have a
separate I mean this is how easy it is
to dumb guys like us who know how to do
nothing
Yeah right we live in a world where us
dumb guys can plug in one of these at
each end get on skype do the podcast and
then we just send it to a guy who's not
it doesn't even live in the same country
as us yeah and he just puts it together
and then it's out that's how you do a
podcast exactly yeah and then my wife
said my wife's starting one my wife
wants because I have the whole mancave
set up she goes I think I'd really enjoy
this we redid our house like I said I
have a purpose in life redoing this
house we got done redoing the house she
was I have no purpose I said I just sort
of podcast she's like with who I know
with your friends just who gives a [ __ ]
just do it and she goes what if it
stinks I go it will it will form a be
forever
maybe yeah or maybe it'll get good and
maybe you'll really enjoy it maybe
you'll stumble onto something that you
love but also the other thing is and
this is I mean this is only from the
consumers perspective now because I'm
like you I'm a massive podcast fan yes
and my favorite like Mike the way that I
feel about certain podcasts is not based
on them being the biggest podcast in the
world like my favorite podcasts aren't
the Game of Thrones of podcast order
whatever they're these things that I
like I mean this is podcast I mentioned
all the time on this podcast but it's
one of the original podcast they've been
around forever
they're amazing it's called oh yeah dude
America through the eyes of two American
Americans just like it's brilliant and
they've been doing it forever they've
done 500 episodes of it and it would
never ever be 0 in the top 10 [ __ ]
podcasts on the podcast charge or
anything but if they stopped trying to
look at no no yes but yes so um it's one
of those things where just like they
have regardless of you know if they're
ever going to be you know seen on all
this widget abuse podcast in the world
or whatever you know the president is
Podcast but to me it's been my favorite
podcast for a decade yeah lately they
have brought joy to my life consistently
in a way that like they amuse me yeah
more than anybody else that I listen to
like it's literally the one podcast that
like you know I loved Kevin Smith
SModcast when I first started yeah but
then I just eventually kind of like
stopped listening and you know this is
the one that I have stuck with and so I
hope that they know that there are
people out there and there'd be people
who feel that about your podcast and I
know there's people who feel that about
our podcast where for them it's brought
in some specific joy that you're like oh
I got to make something like at my
kitchen table right I plugged in some
things and somebody thinks it's the best
thing it's their favorite thing
it's what's getting them through like
there was a guy who goes I did a
five-hour podcast with these two guys
Danish no Neil and all we did was just
kept [ __ ] obliterated and this guy I
was in Cleveland and this guy comes up
and he's like dude more five-hour
podcasts I go takes a lot out of me and
he's like no I Drive a forklift and you
have no idea right I started you in the
morning and then I knew oh I get to go
to lunch and come back and listen to
Bert right I was like oh yeah um I find
that like one of my favorite podcast
I've ever listened to in my entire life
do you know Brody Stevens's yeah okay
Brody this is this is probably six years
ago once I put the people at home that
we probably shouldn't just do we need
context to the psyche of the story
because I already as I said and yes like
he's a very distinct individual light so
Barry he's he I've known Brody for 18
years
um Brody was good presence at Calvin a
kiss he did a show in the States called
enjoy it
where it kind of chronicled him having a
nervous breakdown Brody had a nervous
breakdown Brody's stand-up is very
unique it's very self referential and
it's very um it's he gets takes pride
and stuff no one would take pride in
like his area code he's like eight one
eight til I die and that's like no one
wants to claim it right like over Brody
I'm from Tarzana I know the bus routes
it's really like a really bizarre style
of stand-up but and by the way sometimes
some people could argue no punchlines
book there
funny well it's one of those things to
where he's very much in the vein of a
comedian that if people on the night get
on to what he's doing yeah it's going to
be a really special experience
oh he's also the sort of comedian by the
nature of what he does that if people
don't get onboard it can you know well
for a comedian to watch it it can still
be very very fast for that I ever not
enjoyed a bribe and said yeah but yeah I
was a pitcher in college I have back
hair like right I still call my mom
mommy like he just a really interesting
guy so he did a podcast he did a podcast
with when Brian Redman ran guess quad
guess quad was the label that Rogan was
under and then wrote Brian set up death
squad and started making podcasts for
everybody he did one with Brody and his
roommate Johnny Spanish and I spurred on
will they don't even is it to our my
cats and they don't even get the intro
out right it's all about the intro that
Brody believes Johnny Spanish is [ __ ]
up and it is two hours of them trying to
figure out the intro to a podcast and I
want to treadmill howling laughing going
like cuz it's because it is it is once
again it's not Brody on stage it's a
sign of Brody you don't often get to see
right and it was so authentic that you
were like and he's like and and and one
of my favorite things on podcast is when
people get off mic like that and you can
hear Brody want god damn it Johnny
Spanish you can't mess up the end it is
just genius like oh those like I always
like the the nuances like I like the one
thing I do with my podcast I just start
recording and then someone's like are we
are we started and I go oh yeah that's
because some radio guy did it to me one
time on an interview I call I didn't
call in and he just started talking to
me and we were just bullshitting and
those a hair we gonna start it was I've
already started man and I was like oh
this is a really good conversation to
like brus is talking
I wasn't like Bert on radio right but
yeah I could talk about podcasting all
day long well I mean that's a guy I mean
it's I like the other thing I like about
you know obviously as this world grows
it's expanding now we're in a point of
transition I think in the podcast
industry where you know major players
are recognizing that podcasting is a
thing now and it's a legitimate thing
advertisers are coming to the art form
like you said big celebrities are going
oh I'm going to have my own podcast now
right so it's not like what it was you
know a while ago where you know the few
of us who had podcasts like every year
the joke is now every comedian has a
podcast you know there was a period of
time where it wasn't like that so I
don't mind the idea that occasionally we
stop down and we actually have a chat
about the thing that we're doing because
I think the people listening to a lot of
podcasts also and they don't like like I
can't listen to someone's podcast like
Katie Couric has a podcast she's from
the Today Show here and it was so bad
that I said whatever thought whatever
made you think you could be a
broadcaster morever television like it
was so monumentally bad that I was like
I literally was like I might hate listen
to this and just comment um but yeah I
like the new my favorite murderers I
like that that one that's a really good
podcast yeah I'm going to be in
Australia yeah so we should actually
what let's mention that cohesion I will
plug it as we go along but you are
touring Australia you're coming up with
just for love yeah but and we're doing a
couple of live tofox shows they're just
laughs as well big comedy festival they
have obviously it in Sydney around
Sydney Opera House and it's a week of
fantastic shows uh Joel McHale who was a
guest guest Charlie on the show last
week he's doing some shows down there as
well but you're touring all around
Australia because they offered me the
the the festival yeah I was like oh dude
if I'm going down there I'm hitting like
one of the things I love about this
country and I'm sure you can probably
back me up is like you go to a place
like Vermont or Omaha or Des Moines and
people always go hey man thanks for
coming to Des Moines right like they're
like why did you come to Des Moines
you're like because you're here like
this is what I do
and I need people to watch it and you
happen to live here and you want to
watch it that's how we connect it right
it's you're no different to me than San
Francisco like there's no difference
between San Francisco and Des Moines
your money is exactly the same as theirs
um and so when I got the offer I was
like I was like I'm going to Perth and
they're like everyone's like no not
you've no idea it's in the middle of
nowhere don't go to Perth I go no I'm
going to Perth I go I want to go
everywhere I want to go to Adelaide I
want to go to Brisbane and then there
and everyone was like no you're over
scheduling yourself just do Sydney and
Melbourne that's all you got to do or
Melbourne whatever you ever say it yeah
I mean like you went to that the first
card you were right the second - yeah
but you would like it wasn't offensive
the first thing so I booked a book I
didn't began Hey oddly enough but I
booked Sydney Brisbane Perth and
Melbourne and and approach to the one
that sold the quickest and everyone I've
got more tweets from people going dude
thank you for coming to Perth and I was
like of course it's just as far as
Australia is from here for tip for me it
just happens to be another flight so I
always use decided people like you know
when I started nationally touring you
know early on in my career in Australia
you know you do press in person they
would be a bit like you know even the
press would be like you know oh yeah
good on you for coming and you know what
you and I would always say to them and
say you know this is a pleasure
yeah because people give a [ __ ] that you
came here so the shows are always great
because the audience come along with a
bit of like you know thank you very much
for being here
I'm always like you do a show in Sydney
or Melbourne like yeah yeah come in here
yes coffee's coming here this is where
you come here we go and say Bruce
Springsteen tomorrow this isn't end of
the highlight of my week in fact it
might not even be the highlight of my
heart I'm gonna go and even some
restaurant by some chef who's in the top
10 chefs in the world
- good a highlight of my night I'm
innocent Sydney poor crazy
right exactly I've been to Australia one
other time I had a [ __ ] blast I love
that what what was the previous time
that you came down I went down to do a
TV show and I was turning 40 what was
the TV show that you went on a trip flip
we take two people on adventures of a
life's on okay yeah and so was it was
one of their adventures to go to
Australia on a huge show couples are
they both yeah well I met I we did two
episodes which I got in in Cannes okay
yeah no one in one in Sydney okay and so
we took a couple this was the flaw of
the show also is that I didn't
technically know anything about these
people I just looked at them for a
second made a snap
and said think you're going to be
amazing and we wrongfully pick together
severe rheumatoid arthritis you couldn't
do anything good like we did
what is that it'd be like taking me like
I can't even see be able to do this
[ __ ] he couldn't kneel he couldn't
squat
I couldn't even bend so we did the same
with his Aborigine guy and he wanted us
to sit down yeah and sit in a circle
have a respectful ceremony yeah god I'm
s just kind of squatted like a coach
listening to his horrible horrible and
then we took him like mountaineering and
he couldn't do any of the thing and then
the cold met locked his joints up so he
froze and so we had to lower his body
off a waterfall and like he's drowning
cuz the water bubbles on him and then we
dropped it it was horrible
we didn't so many bad things like that
cuz you didn't know anything he just
goes you guys look great let's go and
then they'd be like awesome and then
you'd like we took a interracial couple
so when you say that you just like pick
them and say let's go yeah we're from
where where he is on the street so you
literally this was a TV show where you
would just go up and find two people on
the street I go here you guys
adventurous and then like yeah I go get
you as you've got more into the show you
learned you had to be more specifically
provide right yeah guy I'd have to say
to black people can you swim right
because it's just a stereotypes there
for a reason but in America but not as
much anymore but there was a period
where black people didn't swim a lot and
it still runs through the community
where you will find black people who
don't know how to swim right and the
truth is like the end this is what I
like about podcast is this moment right
because if we were on stand-up or we
could just leave we could just brush
over this moment right yeah but that was
just you kind of trying to dance around
saying something in a way that you were
like you started saying something and
then you're like it is kind of an
offensive thing to say I mean you were
like well no probably in your head the
reason is that black people couldn't
swim wasn't like black people weren't
trying to swim it was because it's
swimming programs were not in schools
that where black people by communities
and things like that
no because of segregation they weren't
allowed letting in the public pool and
weren't allowed on public beaches and
this is the point normally when it's
something like that it's as a result of
a group in society not be
given access to that yelling and so the
fact that you have to ask is that you
being racist and it's just you've been
careful about not drowning a black
person which i think many in today's
America probably you wouldn't get in
trouble for but what happens is but what
just happened to us we took a couple to
cabo we go out to go swimming with whale
sharks black guys too proud to tell us
you guys never learned how to swim right
and he jumps in the water and starts
drowning yeah and we're like mother and
then I'm in by the way good on him for
thinking he could pick it out Jeremy my
slippers on
yes summers on the spot Keith we in a
wetsuit and he thought wetsuits were
like is good it would make you buoyant
and he just song this will help my
family heavy J got here and jump in
after him oh yeah it was crazy yeah that
you learned you had to ask questions
like that because you had to be a little
bit I guess racist is the right word but
what racists would do is assume things
about people because if you didn't you
could like we took an interracial couple
to South Carolina now I think it would
be racist if you like went up to an
Asian couple and said can you guys try
yes right right right like I think what
you're doing is it just acknowledging a
black blind spot exactly exactly it
would be racist all right that would be
oh we took an interracial couple that I
met in Alaska and I oddly enough i
played in a professional snowball
tournament with this one guy he was a
baseball player right cuz it was Jamal
and I met them and they were cool and I
knew him before and I go dude I got to
take you on a trip and he's like where
anywhere I said where do you want to go
and he was like I've never been to the
lower 48 I was like are you [ __ ] me
because I've never been in the south I
go dude I got a trip to South Carolina
let's do it he's like great and he was
like because he didn't felt like he had
never connected with his
african-american roots cuz he lived in
Alaska so life right and so I was like
dude we're going to South Carolina did
not did not put two and two together
with the trip we had planned was more
based around a white couple probably
because the first thing we did was a
Civil War Reenactment and we pull up and
I'm like oh [ __ ] Jamal yeah he's like
what team are we all like oh we're on
the wrong team brother
and it was uncomfortable and on the run
theme from and then and then we get out
we get out we get our Subaru and he's
like he's like it couldn't get any worse
and I go oh it gets worse on the right
of us it was about to get worse kill
Bruce spending the night an old slave
quarters that were haunted and trying to
see if we can get a haunting to happen
and the reason they were haunted is that
the the man of the house the owner that
had killed the slaves for sleeping with
his wife daughters and now we're putting
an interracial couple in a Rd haunted
house for the reason it was but I got
Jamal [ __ ] I did it better be weird
[ __ ] like that all [ __ ] time I mean
it's almost as if you don't plan and
research things they can go terrible
detail to their own and then stuff will
creep up like you didn't even know like
we had a Jewish director I would I may
kidnappers plan better than you guys did
you have oh my god I want to steal that
line what's yours like I have no other
reason here we had a Jewish director
yeah I need never think about this
I would never this would never cross my
mind the Jews director I find this great
couple white chick and a Palestinian
dude Palestinians dudes parents I guess
got kicked out of ala Stein okay his
real hatred towards Jews and then him
and the directors start [ __ ] really
butting heads on everything and I'm like
I'm oblivious I would never think that's
like someone going like oh I'm
Protestant I'm Catholic I've never that
would never occur to me that there would
be a problem but man we're the middle of
Rio and they're about to fistfight and
it just goes racial instantly and you're
just like holy [ __ ] like where did this
come from and then the couple breaks up
and then I'm sitting in their hotel with
them trying to get them to get back
together so we could finish the episode
it was it was a really interesting show
well at least yeah that I mean it is one
of those things where you realize that
the world is always at different stages
as well because the Protestant Catholic
thing is a good example 50 years ago
that still was an issue and a whole
bunch of places right or whatever now
I'm probably that's maybe a little
longer but the point being it's and
black and white or whatever this is
recent history and in these places where
these they
people are still at war with each other
in the history of dispossession or
whatever you know feels direct you know
it's my family that were moved in this
situation yeah then that hatred can
still bubble over right on the top of
like I mean I the will okay how do you
feel about the world like let's just
jump into it because I because it feels
to me this last week I mean quite like
in the week that we're recording this
this will go out this wake anyway but I
mean it started with Donald Trump
you know essentially almost getting into
a you know worldwide nuclear war on
Twitter with North Korea and then
obviously you know here this week you
know there was the Charlotte ville you
know white supremacy Nazi tiki torch
marches you know I was in I was in
Vermont you know I was in Burlington
Vermont you know amongst the the nice
white people you know and like good one
this sort of people over there get able
to get a lighter torture about to juggle
in a park during a farmers market that
you know and so you're watching the news
and it feels very foreign to the you
know the world that you're walking
around in you know at that time but have
you have you as an American a person who
like you know because I'm it I'm an
immigrant here and I want America to go
well obviously but but it's not my fight
you know it's it's America's fight about
their identity and what they want
America to be that is happening and I
can only kind of be an observer a
traveler through that you know I'd like
to talk to you about you know just
whatever you feel about America right
now is it like is it negative is it
positive how do you feel well I I guess
you have just you have to start with the
fact that I'm a white 44 year old man I
mean I'm Windell India when they when
the election happened I was with Doug
Stanhope bill burr and Rogan we were
doing a live podcast at the store and we
just got offstage we're like [ __ ] man
what the [ __ ] and I don't remember which
one I'm not going to give I'm not going
to say any of them said it but one of
the four of us said gentlemen this
doesn't really affect us in the
slightest this might be the right thing
that ever happened for us because we're
white men with money
that's who you state trying to take care
of so I always said preference
whatever I say about America is I am
white so as a black dude I would have a
very different opinion but I think what
is happening is that people have
polarized so much that no one's willing
to listen to the other side to find a
middle ground like it's either black
lives matters or white nationalists like
what about guys like me who are like I
think but all you were [ __ ] crazy
for I would who wants to spend their
Saturday protesting I would never
protest but once again my life's not
super affected so like I so like I might
I might be the problem like you know
honestly I might I might be the problem
wow there's an argument to be made and I
think it's it's not the first argument
there needs to be fix but it's certainly
one of the arguments and needs to be
fixed which is I'm exactly the same as
you I'm a white rich man like yeah
literally
it's not bad for me you know so even if
you're not a white supremacist you
benefit from a system that is set up for
white supremacy right and the truth is
like I don't tweet anything out about
the white supremacist supremacist only
because I go because I don't that's not
me I don't tweet out politics but then I
go maybe I'm the one that should be
tweeting out like hey guys this is super
unhealthy like but just a lot of [ __ ]
racist I'm part of me goes I'm glad
they're at least saying it out loud
because I've been in the rooms when
they've been saying it quietly right and
I've been I've been around racist people
a lot in my life
a lot well I mean I think this is also a
message that comes out of this is if
anyone thinks this is actually like oh
my god racism's back yeah I racism never
went away I got everyone away racism is
one of those things like a like a pair
of blue jeans it's just keeping me calm
tonight boy James always find you there
will never be a time maybe sometimes
they they need to be a bit skinnier or
we're fat into that bag year or whatever
the whole in term will become
fashionable again in a couple years
racism fear despair guys it's fine it's
crazy because I grew up in the south and
so like I mean racism was very tangible
when I was a kid I remember I was I've
said I've said this on stage it does it
does not need your laugh it never showed
you laugh but I say this just to remind
people how real racism is the first time
I ever heard the
word um I was six years old and these
black kids that come into our
neighborhood and stole my football and
then the left and then they came back in
our neighborhood a week later and
challenged us a bunch of white kids I'm
not all the kids were older than me I
was the youngest they challenged us to a
game of football with my football and
two brothers Darren and Derrick I think
with their names um said that's his
football you need to give it back and
they're like no and then they started
fighting someone wasn't got Darren
Derrick's to add Darren Derek's dad came
next to me and said what's the mountain
he goes I said they stole my football
and they're fighting to get it back he
put his hand on my shoulder he said
start chanting boy fight fight and we're
gonna white white don't win we all jump
in fine fight and we're white I'm six
years old one there's a lot on my
[ __ ] plate I go home I tell my dad
what happened my dad comes down and he's
like why don't you ever [ __ ] touch my
kids don't ever talk to my kid and he's
like my dad's personal like buddy I'll
just get you a [ __ ] football like
don't worry about it
and then we moved out of that
neighborhood within a month because it
was a really redneck neighborhood but
that like just so that was when I was
six so things didn't change globally by
the time I was out of high school right
and then when I got to college you're
you're I went to a school then the
Rodney King [ __ ] starts going down man I
just um I'm saying the MS Pat is a black
woman who does my pockets to me now and
I'm very funny she said one when did you
stop seeing race because as two as a
black versus you're always gonna see
race and as a white person girl in the
south you see race too
I said when I moved to New York it's
when I stopped seeing race for the very
first time in my life like I didn't see
it in high school I didn't see when I
was a child really but like I definitely
witnessed it and then when I got to New
York I remember going like a Maria went
Demetri Martin going like also like
everyone gets on this one bus like
everyone gets on a subway
like I never ridden a bus in Florida
you'd never get on public transportation
in Florida and so I was like whoa like
this is great like you go in a comedy
club you're like you know I'm talking to
Puerto Ricans right now like but I got
two gay guys a Puerto Rican a black guy
then I'm all interacting I was like that
did not happen at Florida State you only
talked to white dudes and white chicks
maybe a couple Cubans you know like it
was just it was just very globally
different Oh
I mean like when I first that I'm in
Seoul Comedy in New York I
it was like the first time I came over
to America you know like I was a young
comedian at that point I was over you
know I might have gone to just the last
and I reckon we took some days in New
York and I just went to some comedy
clubs and watch comedy and I was totally
stunned by how many of the acts had bits
about various nationalities and start I
was like gee do they talk about race and
is this see a lot in this country but
what I realized was because I was making
a judgement like our people here are
much more aware of that and I was like
oh no no no like I just performed not
like white Australian audiences and
they're performing to this like
incredibly diverse group of people so
they have to have a sense of what each
of those groups are and you know what
their characteristics are and how to
relate for it like I remember I remember
performing in like meaning like you're
talking about people with life
experiences they don't connect with your
life experiences so like I remember
performing in the Boston comedy club for
a group of 10 Puerto Rican guys and
think talking to them about life and
girls the way I had experienced it
thinking I could observationally comedy
on my way into their life and they were
laughing so hard at what I was talking
about my experiences with girls and one
of them I go I know you know what I mean
I goes do we have no [ __ ] idea what
you mean he's like we're just here he's
going to prison tomorrow we took him out
for a good time and I was like oh my god
I've never had I've never had to take my
friends out the prison for prison like
I've never been like guys tonight before
we go to prison let's all go take you
out like I was like oh we have nothing
in common like we have almost nothing in
common
I used to think again like I'm going to
make a judgment that I often make about
people who take their bachelor parties
to a comedy night
yeah there's somewhere else that
everybody wants to be yeah comedy is not
the first choice they got the wrong guy
to plan the night before prison party
because well you I think of the things
that you're gonna miss in prison
stand-up isn't one of them I feel like
there's some other things you'd rather
do run I'd better get those laughing
just because before I go in its yeah New
York wasn't saying that I moved out to
LA I always said that did the difference
in the two different places of do
stand-up it's working out like New York
is like working out the prison yard with
a broomstick and cinder block you're
just getting big enough so that you
can't get
salted in the shower like that's how
stand-up is there because it is in your
face it is it is very interactive and
then I came out to LA and I had this
like prison body like for standup
I remember getting on stage I was
hosting for Drew Carey I don'ts get on
stage and I just came I was like where's
the Puerto Ricans at like because I was
like God I need a Puerto Rican so I can
start my act I need a black guy I need
two gang guys I need a bunch of lesbians
are like angry and I was like oh I don't
have any jokes I don't have any jokes
and I was like oh la is like working out
where you look like a fitness model
you're not right you can't defend
yourself but you look good yeah and so
it so you would see LA come as good as I
work and be like so I was driving on the
street the other day and you just hear
black Jews go nah dude next ha ha he was
like I'm not done yet I'm not done yet
he's like now you're done Donald it was
it was and then you go on the road in
the in the middle of our country and
you're like the best Road comics are
guys who can do New York and LA
interchangeably right and make it
authentic but have material like make it
interactive but be sure that you're
doing material well the thing so we were
having a little conversation before we
started the podcast and so I'm going to
continue I thought we were talking about
them but we were talking about the idea
you you would asking about me about the
idea of the value of telling a story to
your own audience you know the audience
you know who listened to the podcast
we've come out to see you who allow you
to have that like deeper level of
understanding and in your story they get
it a bit more versus taking that story
to you know some club where they don't
know you're all and making it work there
I always think the only mistake that
people make is where they they
disrespect their own act when if they
say if I'm going to play the south or if
I'm going to play bah bah blah I need
some jokes about this rather than going
how do I make what it is that I want to
say to everybody just work in these
different places they like yeah louis
c.k said the art form is making
strangers laugh that's he goes that's
the art form you know and I guess at the
time he was not as famous as he was
someone was asking him why don't you do
the UCB and he goes because if I go in
there everyone knows me and it's not I'm
not gonna have a hard time
rather go work out in a comedy club
where there are people who don't know me
and this was this apply 13 years ago
when he said this but and so I was like
I was like yeah because I was doing the
road at the time I was like yeah
making strangers laughter then you said
something that was genius
because I would and and this is what it
really blew my mind so I'm having a hard
time because I go to the store like I'll
be at the store tonight and I know
granted I haven't done this for a while
but like some of my bits I feel like are
almost too nuanced of you have to know
who I am you know like and and I and I
go does that mean they're not funny
because I take them on the road and they
murder and I go okay
like um and then you were saying oh no
it's like lost like you can't just watch
season 4 episode 8 of lost and go this
is a great show I know I've unlocked it
and then I was like yeah it's some
comics are like Seinfeld like Anthony
Jeselnik is sought as like it's like an
episode of Friends right you don't need
to know the backstory right I can just
watch one episode because it is Radio
News radio right you can watch the news
radio and laugh your dick off but like
if you see me I am NOT parts of my actor
news radio life and I don't think that I
like but I think isn't there an element
to though to kind of extend that point
where maybe what it does make you do a
little is just find shorter sharper
establishing ways to set up who you are
or at least the bits of it you that they
need to know to understand the story on
the level the other like so for example
it's like the thing I always talk about
is like safe say I meet you at a party
right first time we meet we introduce
each other other fully we talk about
what jobs we have we talk about like do
you have a wife do we have kids like do
you have dogs bah bah bah bah blah blah
blah right but the next time we meet you
don't have to like do all that again you
take off from where you left off right
when you're playing in new audiences
like when you're just doing your own
stuff to your own audience you don't
have to reintroduce yourself again every
night this is who I am this is what I'm
like they know that so you can just tell
your story but I think there's a way of
quickly introducing yourself to an
audience in a way like certainly when
I'm on the road the first five minutes I
very clearly talking about a thing about
Australia or a thing about like where I
grew up a thing about blah blah blah
just a few things that you need to know
about me a few jokes in that early bit
that define me in
like you know a way that will be
necessary for the way that you're going
to need to know that I understand the
world for the rest of the show like I do
think there's a quick way of like short
handing and them straight in to where
they need to be yeah I think I think on
my last special I did that really well
like I like but like I did a joke about
my daughters and I because I had these
great jokes about my daughters that were
worked universally but um but I I needed
to explain that my youngest daughter is
a little different not not not nothing
wrong with her but she's just weird
right and so the joke was I have two
daughters
George's 12 blond hair blue eyes
beautiful real smart and I got another
one and so like that was the setup now
when I'm telling like now when I started
story about my daughter's I go I go I'm
assuming everyone knows when I say
island we know what's about to happen
but you're right sometimes I don't
establish hey my daughter is weird as
[ __ ] right
and so yeah I don't know it's been an
interesting hour I uh does this hour
that I'm doing it working on I learned a
lot doing my last hour but this one I go
what did you learn tell me - tell me
what you learned about pacing um cuz I
got I kind of had a departure from like
jokes my last hour I departed from any
joke I tried to write any joke that
anyone else could write meaning like I
really was like bummed when you'd write
a joke like I remember doing Last Comic
Standing and I had a great joke a really
great joke I was very proud of it you
know what cops hate when you touch their
faces we try this when they come through
it by the way this is a like textbook
Dave Attell ripoff Dane Cook ripoff
right right I got the Dave Attell set up
and then you know do next I'm coming to
window the cop comes he's like you know
I pulled you up or take your lips put it
to a bigger finger put as those lips ago
she Shh and then take off you know so
it's like Simon Simon Simon my voice how
many I wrote it but it's not me right
I thought it was so original I get up on
there and every comic that did Last
Comic Standing how to joke about getting
pulled over by the cops and I went so
I'm just one of them like I'm not I
don't my gonna make myself stand out so
then I was doing that for a long time
and then I then I told the Machine story
and I went and someone said to me for
like
that's I mean no one can do that no one
can take that from you and I was like oh
yeah I'm just gonna take stuff that's
very authentically me and just do that
my thing so in the last hour I had I
went okay I got this great story about
my daughter put her finger out and
putting the dog's mouth I'm gonna put
that it was murdering and I was like but
I'm murdering too much I need to slow
down the pacing with some ethos or
pathos up against which ones which so
I've been slowed it down with another
story and then did some other stuff and
then slowed it down and did another
stuff so I was like okay it can't just
be murderous throughout you've got to
tell a story you've got for me at least
you got to tell you got to tell you got
an arc and you got to end big so I
learned about how to slow the audience
down to give them a minute to breathe
and then and then and but not lose them
to keep them engaged and I'm not doing
that on this hour right now I have a
really great 30 minutes it's really
great right and then nothing else okay
like nothing else I have like three
other stories but none of them are
connecting would be up like that was the
other thing I was connecting parts of
the hour and it's all connected right
and so now I just have this and then
nothing and like like three other good
stories that are totally detached but
another thing I was going to say that
like sometimes in those situations and
I'm only speaking from my own personal
experience here obviously because
everybody is very different but often
what I will find is say I am working on
like you know and and you know I've got
I've got like I'm working to try to get
60 or 70 together and like you know I've
got sort of 40 or 50 that's working and
then I've got another 30 or 40 still
that like just you're just like I can't
get any of this [ __ ] to quite you know
gel in the way that other you know bit
is often I just think get rid stop
trying to make this [ __ ] you can't make
work work and just lean in a little
harder to this at 3 things that are
working yeah sometimes I think you know
what make up instead of me trying to
find a whole new bed what if I can find
another minute or two minutes in that
story that's already great that actually
not only adds something else to that
story but like gives me another kind of
thought or
feet or you know something else within
the stuff that already has this system
around it that works so if I take a beat
like if I try a mineral to hear and it
doesn't work I can just take it back out
again and stories like great you know
but I often think build the stuff that's
working and [ __ ] off the stuff that is
what I try to do well my big thing right
now is is it's a lot I guess it's a lot
imagine if you could cut and paste
marble so like I I I had this joke about
this hand job my wife gave me of how bad
it was
oh I've watched it in San Francisco and
she goes I really think you're past
doing hand jobs right I go I go yeah but
it's good excuse
I go yeah but I got this great lines a
lime in there and she goes been great
get rid of the joke and keep that one
line and put it somewhere else but I
went oh yeah I guess I could do that
she's like that's what you always do and
I go I not what I always do but I guess
I could try it and so so right now right
now I just want to I want I the 30
minutes is all is all about one thing so
I just need other parts of my
personality right to put to sprinkle in
there yeah and so I don't know and then
I was like I said to something that's
the great thing about like I mean all
side the other great thing about you
know comedy and like looking at comedy
you know the more you do of it and like
you know I've heard you talk to people
on your podcast and I've heard you talk
another podcast so I think this is
probably a philosophy that you share
which is this idea of like really at the
end of days just it's about being fun
yeah like it's about finding your way to
be funny yeah like we look at it like
there's some sort of code or formula or
whatever you know do you need to have it
like this or it needs to work like this
but but it does it like the [ __ ] joke
could go to what look you could
literally make two very different
decisions on one thing that's not quite
working right so you're doing the
[ __ ] bit and you're like this is not
quite great
you can do two things that's the great
thing about comedy is like you exercise
it take the one good line and put it
somewhere else yeah that's a totally
valid thing to do or you can do the
other thing of going right well now I'm
going to do this bit and then I'm going
to do a bit about the conversation I
have with my wife about the fact that I
was past [ __ ] jokes and like you know
kind of turn
they'll thing about like not only the
bit but like you know then the
conversation you have with her about the
bit which tells you something about you
know you and her like that the [ __ ]
joke probably doesn't mean like and then
it becomes this other thing that also is
kind of symbolic of you having a
conversation about whether you're beyond
[ __ ] jokes or not you know I mean
like it says something like whatever
great thing about comedy is you can go
such different ways with you know those
sort of the she didn't want it one of my
favorite things that louis c.k did ever
was a he allowed he he put his stamp on
comedy and said hey it doesn't have to
be brilliant it can just be eat a bag of
dicks Ryan just if it makes me giggle
I'm gonna put it in there and I was like
oh that's pretty like like because I got
a pretty low brown sense of humor I love
I love I just like being surprised the
other day I want to be surprised I want
to be in the room and be surprised at
what I hear if you ever seen that guy
because I know you mentioned Ricky
Gervais earlier and I will say I have a
complicated relationship with the work
of Ricky Gervais like I I I like love
the office logged loved most of extras
yeah did not care for Derek at all sat
down Derek that was the one where he
pretended to be a kind of like semi
[ __ ] so did not enjoy that felt like
that was not for me and he's like I'm
not a religious person like I'm a person
who doesn't believe in God but like the
way that he talks about not believing in
God online makes me want to believe in
God just to react to like you know it's
everything but all that's it regardless
of all that there's this moment this is
series he did with Chris Rock and louis
c.k and Seinfeld and they're all sitting
around talking about comedy and there's
a stand-up because this was at a time
where like I've done stand-up along in
the wreckage of a says you know I think
a lot of people yeah well that's right
but then he kind of got parachuted into
this level of sitting around with
regardless of your taste three of the
greatest comedians of all time right and
then suddenly you're looking at like I
mean the office was a guy and you're a
great container in comedian and whatever
but you're you should not be sitting at
this table you know like and there's and
you can tell just from the way that he
he has a bit more like open Michael
ideas about comedy yeah you know just a
bit more because when you first start
you have all these rules and all these
things that you think are true and then
what you realize eventually is there is
no fashion like I mean it's just getting
it done whatever [ __ ] gets it done
and allows you to get it done that's how
you do it right and it changes and it
changes all the [ __ ] time and the
minute you think you've cracked the
formula you haven't cracked the formula
and yeah but there's this moment in that
way Ricky gets a particularly
pretentious and then Louis tells the
story about us the funniest thing ever
saw was this guy like this bus go down
on the docks singing sitting on the dock
of the bay but he changed the loo stirs
sitting on my [ __ ] cuz I'm gay or
whatever and like it's just the right
moment like yes because sometimes that
is yeah sometimes that's the funny bit
oh the nose I got I think I remember um
I when I first started stand-up I
remember being very finding my voice
very quickly and we did this
storytelling room me and this guy DC
Benny and ended up Ben Bailey and DC Ben
he took it over but me and DC buddies a
storytelling room and I went in and I
told five stories that all made it into
my comedy specials in that room and I
went I found my voice very quickly then
like an open mic er I got my way so I'm
like I'm not doing what everyone else is
doing
I need a dick joke I need to joke about
dick jokes I need a joke about homeless
people I need to joke about taxis I need
joke about subways and so and I was like
I often believe that you know if you go
to an open mic night or like an early
like because even there's a bit you know
use like I found my voice pretty early I
think most people arrive at their first
gig with their voice yes yeah and then
you start to [ __ ] put [ __ ] in the way
of like I mean it's over [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of me over like I overthought
my standup because I what mattered more
to me was Patrice or a telling like hey
man that was a good bit I remember Dave
Attell I had one bit and Dave Attell
came up and was like that's funny the
joke was when I was a kid I watched a
movie called beat Street about tagging
so I thought that'd be cool so I went to
the gate at the front of my
neighborhood that little sign had
Faircloth states on it got expanded
spray-paint was like and then I was like
oh [ __ ] I'm the only Bert in this
neighborhood so then I wrote sucks [ __ ]
and @l came over to me was like that's a
great bit I was like okay I got write
more like God I got more you know
because I got the but that's I mean the
night sir probably the history of comedy
a lot of the time has been that I mean
we're all formed by our environments
yeah I wish I I think I probably
would've been a much better stand up
quicker had I started in like in a place
where I didn't respect the comics you
know yeah like I started campus you guys
talk I'm doing my own thing but then I
started with GI people around me and
you're like well if I want to be a
genius I have to be the amount of x over
D is like you know when you sit down to
write something you know where I sit
down and go well what yo what's
so-and-so doing what should I be doing
and they're like what the [ __ ] you doing
yeah like why are you like firstly
that's what they do it's not what you do
but secondly why comparing like this is
not the [ __ ] Olympics mate it's like
you're an artist like I mean the whole
point of this is that you get to make
what you want to make like and you know
maybe heaps of people like it or maybe
some people like it I've got a whole
bunch of different podcasts and the
thing that like really this is such a
[ __ ] bizarre thing to say but it
really for a while
was problematic to me that they all had
very diverse numbers of listeners like I
was like because there's a part of you
that just wants everyone to love
everything you do equally right yes but
what you've got to kind of come to terms
with and certainly through the podcast
process to bring it back to that this is
one lesson that's taught me is you know
my podcasts on this does heaps better
than my podcast on this but I don't
differentiate between the two about one
being the favored over the other I do
them because I like doing them the more
and sometimes with my stand-up which
should be exactly the same you're like I
know that's why you just you just meant
to be doing it what saying whatever you
tell whatever story you want to tell
will say whatever it is that you have to
say if this was the last time that
anybody was ever going to say like
see you do what you want to do what is
it you would want them to be left with
yeah and then that way you can go well
I'd like them to think I'm a real fun
guy so this better be really fun I don't
want to all be serious or maybe I'd like
to do a few serious things that I really
need to say if this is the last time
anyone like and try to just funnel that
into a [ __ ] entertaining show it's an
argument for saying that like you look
at that and then you go what I've ever
had the balls to be carrot top like what
I ever have had the balls to be like I
don't give a [ __ ] what anyone thinks
right I'm doing what I want to do and
it's working and I like it she's seen
it's his thing like I mean that's the
when you get to that point where you be
judgmental of people like that you're
like oh no it's just [ __ ] you know
what and the other thing about being mad
at carrot top is Carrot Top is not
taking my gigs not at all like you know
I can name some people you know who are
similar to me who you go okay what if I
could do if I was gonna you know hate
someone I'll be jealous of somebody I
know choose not to like because I often
think anyway to be honest if carrot top
gets a whole bunch of gigs it opens
doors for people who are more like
carrot top that's the way the industry
actually works right
like it doesn't no one's ever taking
your [ __ ] job but certainly carrot
tops not taking anybody's job oh yeah I
had someone critical of me the other
night not then I was a little while ago
at the store because I take my
performing my shirt off and this guy was
like are you [ __ ] serious and I go
it's what I do
I'm not like I'm comfortable about my
shirt on like why do you care what I
wear on state like what like it but I
but I didn't say that I actually went I
know I'm such a hack and but then I was
like no not like I do it well obviously
it's done hacky it's not like there's a
hole there's no one's performed with
your shirt off of me yeah it's not like
maybe it's not that you can get like
five other acts together to do the
no-collar comedy just so color comedies
dude it's it is it is insane he's what I
what really frustrates me is when you
find someone who's feels because what
what that is is you know one of the
things that me and you have in common
and Stanhope and and Burr and Rogan and
I know I've had this conversation with
with Stanhope and Rogan is that there is
there have been and there will be times
we're
we have nothing to say but we still get
on stage and try things that we don't
know if they're funny or not people who
steal see that hurdle get in that
foxhole and they panic and they go I
can't leave man I'm just gonna try his
I'm gonna do his stuff and that's one of
the things I can't respect people who
steal because I go I go you don't and
you're not allowed to do that when we go
to war you got to jump out of the
foxhole just like I did you gotta get on
stage and try something new interesting
what you say because before when you
were talking about that idea of like
telling a story that only you could tell
yes because in my career a lot of the
stuff that I did particularly early on
cuz I had like a TV show that was all
about like politics and sort of news you
know so so a lot of my stuff was about
you know news items and things that were
happening in the world and as we've seen
from Twitter now and people have a
better understanding of it if Donald
Trump does something today you will see
like a hundred jokes in a second or
begley the same junk because of your
using the same source ingredients yeah
you'll have that and early on I was like
well this is really problematic because
eventually you know you've got a few
things in your set that people are going
to be like well that sounds a bit too
familiar to blah blah blah
not because it's like a bit or so what
you I had to decide to do for for that
very reason is going if I'm going to
talk about an issue it can't be just hey
gay marriages in the news or hey you
know blah blah blah so for example in my
show I've given examples I've got a
better explanation of it I wanted to
talk about living in America and what's
happened here with the election and
those sort of things but I didn't like
easy you can't just go hey remember that
thing that Trump said and tell a joke
because even if I've never seen it there
will be 300 versions of something on
that topic out there in the world right
so if you're going to talk about Trump
you have to have a personal legitimate
experience and angle on it yeah that
could only be your personal legitimate
experience yes to make sure that you
just can't even wait into those waters
right so so for example I tell the story
of flying to America being in the air
when he was elected like I got on a
plane when it was neck-and-neck and like
we were flying to America with a group
of people who never imagined that would
happen so I tell that story and then
within that I'm able to give you a sense
of what I think about that and what my
perspective is on that but you've got to
kind of find that unique and personal
angle that could be what no one else
yeah you know the jokes in this no one
else could tell because no one else
could be level actually funnily enough I
was also flying too you know and but it
tells you something about me it's the
opening part of my show because I get to
explain to you in the team that I split
split half my life between these places
he's my perspective you know here's what
I'm kind of telling you about myself in
relating this personal anecdote but
hopefully that is telling you a whole
bunch of other things it's funny because
you watch a lot of people try to do what
Burr does like burr has got such a great
biting sense of humor right now and you
watch a lot of young guys try to emulate
him and I'm like why you gotta find your
own you gotta find your own lane because
he does that so [ __ ] well you are
never going to out burr Bill burr well
the other thing though I think it makes
bill work because I've said this many
times on the podcast before he's one of
my favorite comedians and I disagree
with 90% of what he says yeah and so
he's always a great example to me of the
fact that you in no way have to agree
with the performer on stage to enjoy
them and the idea that like you know
somehow if I'm going to have an opinion
about something I'll talk about
something that the audience need to
agree with me to enjoy it like that's
not necessary firstly secondly the thing
that works about Bill's level of that is
that you get a sense that it's just
legitimately bill I remember seeing bill
like 15 years ago
and he was as mad then about [ __ ]
avocado as you know use about [ __ ] now
like the reason that I can enjoy a lot
of the time him talking about ideas and
concepts that I personally am confronted
by ago that is not how I view the world
at all bill is because you know that
that's how you've used everything yeah
also you know that he's not like that
offstage as a comedian like you know how
generous and kind of lovely he is
actually as a human being but but on
stage even if you don't know that it's
the fact that it's all that and it's
genuinely legitimately Bill yeah
works if you then just go and copy that
it's like the people who saw Bill Hicks
and just decided to write jokes about
you know aliens and whatever like we all
I mean don't get me wrong like I I was
also a young comedian 22 years ago you
know dude is the it's funny because
Patrice was but bird tackles a subject
that he thinks you don't agree with
Patrice used to bring up subjects no one
agreed with right no like he would be I
remember him going one time he's like
how old do you think what's the age the
perfect days to [ __ ] a kid and you were
just like and no one was like and he was
like I mean you know I mean God says 13
and you're just sitting there going like
what the I mean his elephant in the room
is the best special I've ever seen
everyone is my favorite special I've
ever seen um well he's another great
example of somebody who you know again
who's you know ideas and perspectives
you know I would like well I mean it but
you would always be confronted by but I
mean he was just dead to it funny as
well to heat you know so funny is that
like and I think anyone who knew Patrice
would say the same is that how many
people like him versus how many of those
people Patrice would have liked right he
did not like anybody I mean we saw a
comedian no comedian named Ed Byrne yeah
I was at the artists committee we were
friends we had but me I I went to go see
ed in a [ __ ] play 1,600 seater with
Patrice and we sat there and he just
[ __ ] on his act the whole time and just
a [ __ ] ain't funny
that [ __ ] ain't funny what the [ __ ] it
is they were laughing at Bert what are
we doing here what are we doing just
[ __ ] on his act and then Edie loved
degrees of water like we he's so excited
that the trees came to see his show and
like all thanks for coming up she's like
man I wish I could have gotten out of it
but like she did not like anybody it was
he was the best man that was I genuinely
miss him I didn't go to his funeral
because I heard Patrice my head going
you really gonna pay to fly out see me
no I wouldn't
like you got to respect the relationship
you have with the man even in death
right yeah you're just like this is what
a would I want it yeah I would love to
have I would love he had still been
alive for this Trump stuff well so this
is interesting to me because it's I
think there's a real clamoring for
voices like this is a moment where you'd
love to say Chris Rock get back to the
best of Chris Rock or we feel like
there's a clamoring in the community for
for Dave Chappelle I see there's
unrealistic pressure sometimes you're
right yeah that's like the most
brilliant same it's unrealistic pressure
because it I don't think I don't think
that Chappelle's Lane right like I don't
think as much as I think people want him
to be a social commentator Dave at his
heart I think was just a silly guy that
like giggling and getting high right and
playing video games listen to music and
now everyone's like you need to be the
voice of the black people and Chris Rock
had that but you know I think people
forget Chris doesn't technically write
all his material right so like his first
hour was I mean that we all loved was
like Nick DiPaolo rich Voss day louis
c.k i'm it was all his best friend
helping him craft that hour so you know
unlike bill who writes all his own stuff
by himself
Chris doesn't so I don't know I have a
hard time compartmentalizing my love for
that comment versus like louis c.k
writes everything himself every word
that i every word that comes out of my
mouth what came from my brain um you
know dave is the same way i remember i
remember today that uh in dayton he came
into the office when i was getting paid
his walked in i was like just like
seeing a great white shark in the wild
you're like oh [ __ ] I forgot you lived
in Ohio and he was like I was like how's
everything going it's like I don't have
any material and as opposed to someone's
like everything's great I got my team of
writers watching my set and they're
gonna help me figure out this hour Oh
who the [ __ ] like so Chris Rock's
knocking it not going to be that voice I
mean I'm being a dick but not on earth
but I've met but it all unless he
decided that he wanted to be in and
hired a whole bunch of people
to do that for that reason like it it
but my point of name checking both of
those people is I think you're asking
people again like you said Chappell who
you know I think it's been foisted upon
him yes and rock who it's not you know
that there was a time where he was that
but he's not really that anymore you
know he's got a special coming out maybe
it may be talking about well you just
did Australia now apparently a lot of
it's about his divorce and stuff like
that more than you know other stuff so
exactly it's funny do you think do you
think when you establish yourself as a
social commentator like Chris Rock's
black people versus Anwar is one of the
best bits ever but like do you think
then people see was that and don't want
to know oh yeah I'm also a man who wants
to [ __ ] but uh salon J or whatever well
ok again I didn't say the show and it
looked Chris Rock's one of the you know
the most successful comedians of all
time so I'm essentially but breaking
down what I think the problems of his
show were based on hearsay from my
friends who saw the show but he's my
theory excited my theory is that you
could do a [ __ ] brilliant thing about
the fact that you treated on your wife
with salon J and you know the mistakes
you made and what it was like to be this
kid who suddenly was like this massive
star in the fact that you you were the
one you were the one who [ __ ] it up
you know you were the one who got it
wrong and you were the one who cheated
and all those sort of things and if
Lilly wanted to do that or Bill wanted
to do that or a bunch of other people
wanted to do that I would [ __ ] line
up around the block and go great I'm
gonna go and see that show that'll be
[ __ ] amazing but what I feel like
he's not doing is that there's a lot
about how much money she got you know
that she go
yeah if you understand you know like
that sort of like an idea of gum I don't
know if that's what I want to hear I
don't want to hear a guy who like
because it is the thing 49 percent of
Chris Rock's money is still more money
than anybody else in that audience is
ever going to earn in their last so the
idea that that in somehow is relatable
like I guess the idea of like here's
somebody getting half in the divorce is
relatable to people yeah but the idea
that you're on stage kind of complaining
about that fact that she took 51 percent
you're like yeah you got 49 percent a
Chris Rock money you just
two specials at Netflix for fifty
million dollars yeah tell us how you
were wrong tell me something about you
give me something about how you [ __ ]
this up rather than just you know drop
it a hint that you [ __ ] someone in
Destiny's Child like yeah I feel like
this could be great material in there
like but I think these men and women
stuff has never been my favorite stuff
of his anyway I liked his other stuff
more but the reason that all this
happened was that you said Patrice
they'd be great to hear what he said and
I think that's what it would have been
great time for it would have been a
great time for a new voice like it might
have been one of those times where
someone like Abbott race he's so
respected within the community but and
of course you know I mean obviously
people knew him from the television and
all those sort of things but a voice
like that in these times you could
imagine he would wouldn't have got
softer he would have got harder you know
that's the you're seeing that and you
know the times would have been suited
for him you know in you know do you ever
hear is joke about Michael J Fox ah he
goes this is right well Michael's a fire
comes out with an S or whatever he's got
Lou Gehrig's disease no no no not the
character change it to Michael J Fox
disease look like because he's like you
know what we build a bigger
he's got whatever he has he's got I
think he's got I don't know
anyway he's got whatever Muhammad Ali
had Hawkinsville Parkinson's yeah yes I
yeah and he comes out and he goes uh
this is the day Michael J comes out at
time a Parkinson's disease and he goes
man I saw Michael J Fox got Parkinson's
you came on the TVs I go we need two
ways awareness we need to raise money
that's just some disingenuous [ __ ] he
goes I would love to be a reporter in
that room to go and Michael what about
AIDS and cancer and those horrible
diseases and he goes I respect the man
if he's like yeah the problem with AIDS
and cancer is I don't got that [ __ ] and
then he goes and then his [ __ ]
got the nerve to try to out shake the
champ he said next Muhammad Ali going I
got a voice and he does you can't I'll
shake the champ but by the way this is
the day Michael Jacobs I mean way to go
the most beloved star in America
announced that he has like it Heroica
Lee announced yes not only does he have
mr. days but he's beginning to become a
champion for it yes good reason [ __ ]
on it so hard oh he was man he would be
a great voice but one I think you're
right I think what we do is we put this
we put this responsibility on guys like
Chris Rock and Dave Chappelle to be
something that quite honestly they're
probably never wanted to be right like a
Dave Chappelle I don't think ever wanted
meant I'm sure he wanted to be famous
but up I'm sure there was no version of
what he is today when he started he
couldn't be like I want to be something
though that no one's ever seen before a
mythical creature that [ __ ] shows up
and people lose their minds he might be
the most famous comic ever right and you
won't like it but you know but that's
the thing right like you know you
couldn't plan out like people go I want
a Chappelle career okay okay so what
you're going to get a real hot save Asia
you're going to walk away from like
millions yeah they're gonna do [ __ ] my
brother but it will get destroy every
three and a half hours shows yeah it is
it here on Ohio in the morning [ __ ]
like that's where that's where it goes
you know what I have a theory that I
would love to hear your insights on
because part of me goes you can't you
can't replicate what happened with spell
but then I watched Larry the Cable Guy
one night and um and it really changed
the way I looked at stand-up and it was
like don't overthink it like just like
we were when we were young comics don't
overthink it I watched Larry and he has
the sleeveless shirt and he's one of his
jokes is I don't know about you but I
think this global warmin stops horse
crap he was I think the Lord takes the
temperatures and the place went [ __ ]
nuts
I don't want dumb it down like don't
overthink don't overthink it
don't like just be what they want you to
be like and then I tried it one night I
go I don't know about you guys I like it
and drunk by myself and they go [ __ ]
nuts I'm like I could do this all night
yes hey guys who wants another drink
back shirts off ah like and then I think
sometimes and I don't I think that's
what's beautiful about Chappelle is that
he doesn't overthink it he just does
exactly what his brain tells him to do
and he does it and then you look at guys
that you go all they're definitely
overthinking it right like oh you're
it's a what is it call paralysis by over
analysis yeah
I'm fat like you look at some guys
career and you're like shouldn't you
shouldn't have thought about it at all
well but the problem is though like I
mean here's the thing I'm from a dairy
farm so my parents are dairy farmers
their parents were farmers and my
brother is a farmer my dad lives on the
road that he was born on he's never
moved anywhere off that road 250 people
in the entire area I grew up to the
first 17 years of my life so he yeah so
I'd never met anybody in show business
I've met had never met a stand-up
comedian I'd heard a couple of Billy
Connolly albums and a couple of Bill
Cosby albums and you know when I first
started doing stand-up I'd seen a few
gallows on the TV and those sort of
things but really I didn't have much of
a sense even of what stand-up is so
along the way you have to just like I
mean I always say to people when I
started it was still running away to
join the circus yeah we're kind of a
generation we're you know maybe half a
generation behind where it is now but
like no one there was no frame of
reference for what a comic was when I
told my god I wanted to be comedian he
was like buddy I don't know what to tell
you like he was like what do you do I go
I think I'm gonna move to New York I
mean there was no internet to show you
what a comic right you couldn't listen
to a bunch of podcasts and got on that
like you know that no idea of like dying
or you know getting something wrong or
having you know thought that somebody
else has had and how you deal with that
or like all these sort of things that
we're talking about you can now just sit
and listen to a podcast and go ah ah
everybody everybody's had that exact
same thing happen to them yeah it turns
out that I'm not the worst person ever
in comedy yeah oh god yeah like there
was no frame of reference I didn't know
like I'm a repeat I remember going I was
from the generation where I went to a
comedy club once and you had to go ask
the comic hey how do I become a comedian
but as opposed to now it's everyone
knows oh I just go do another mic I
didn't know there was an open mic hadn't
know anything about that you know so
funny all I could think about is when
you said that that you started listening
to Bill Cosby albums I wonder because a
comic no always writes about what is
authentically going in there lot on in
their life and what if you get peruses
album and albums and find anything about
drugging and raping chips
well there is apparently really so yeah
I mean firstly all the titles of the
albums now because I was actually
cleaning out some stuff at home and
found a whole bunch and they all have
named
that have not aged well in light of the
allegations against them are they've all
just yet there's this awful people
yeah there's a whole like really like
every one of them reads bad now the ring
blows yet even just the best of Bill
Cosby you're like no no no none of them
have ID well bill but there is some
people have gone through and there's
actually then in fact there's one story
that is essentially about drugging
somebody we know that was super common
in the 70s like right yeah you know
there was up when that Bill Cosby thing
came out there were people a couple
people that I think they play scrub the
internet like even Hugh Hefner was like
some girl was like know when I met Hugh
Hefner he gave me a quaalude to loosen
up and he's like oh yeah we call him
panty droppers I mean his stories around
it you don't want to dig too deep into
you know that scene that was around
David Bowie and Mick Jagger and all that
sort of the parties they were going to
and all those sort of things a lot of
that stuff I mean and again a lot of it
like wasn't is I mean [ __ ] who knows it
was different times who [ __ ] knows
like you know what else but but it aDNA
but what we were why were we talking
about them talking about Oh cuz you were
talking about getting into stand-up is
kind of like joining the circus oh yeah
I mean doesn't matter anyway we should
finish up we go well it's an hour and 20
and we've got other [ __ ] to do so
obviously [ __ ] know if it four o'clock
okay oh yeah a little talking yeah okay
that's one of the best conversation I've
ever had well let's have a pause then
and then we'll I'm going to get a
bathroom well cool
[Music]
all right we're back we're back we had a
little break but we're back I was going
to get a drink but I forgot to get a
drink but it's okay I got enough there I
can get straight into the podcast I will
keep you too much longer
I don't know you're like a mocking
you're not keeping me at all in fact I
you know I'm happy to continue talking
but I you know I was just cognizant of
the fact that it was also Monday morning
and you know you had spoken to me about
the fact that you have quite a busy
weekend and also we'd [ __ ] just got
some gold out already so I thought
people would you know if nothing else
I'd already got their free podcast worth
of it oh yeah my friends this is just
vibrating I started looking at what
makes my podcast good like where my
numbers were so like I told you I did
that five hour podcast and it would
double my numbers my numbers doubled to
that I was like that's odd and then I
found out when I drank my numbers jumped
right so if I drink and I do a long one
people lose their minds
yeah I mean that's you know not great
for you yeah your future health look if
you have to buy drinking anyway if you
have to tie yourself to that business
model like you know same Burt you know
he's actually been doing a podcast
since mate literally just he's drinking
drinking constantly hasn't been asleep
yet it's um it's funny cuz I don't drink
on stage technically right like I only
neatly
whatever somebody are you bring a drink
on I bring a drink on if someone sends a
shot I don't turn it down right I don't
get drunk on stage um like I did three
shows Saturday in Houston and I drank
one Cheetos and soda on The Late Show in
11:30 that's it but everyone thinks I'm
[ __ ] hammered like everyone thinks so
it's like a great business model for me
because I do like to get hammered so
when I do get hammered no one blames me
but I don't perform hammered so like so
I got like I will go in and do press and
drink it press because I go I want to be
here
like it's 6:00 in the morning right all
over and then they're like you want a
drink I'm like yeah let's do it
so then times I go on TV drunk and
people are like did you see him but
anyone who's a fans like I [ __ ] loved
it I when we type not my last special
but a special before it was at the
Sydney Opera House and it was the first
time that I'd ever
come on yeah maybe was the first time
I'd ever played the main room at the
Opera House and a visitor there's two
and a half thousand maybe it's a decent
room and it's it's the end but it's also
it's the main room at the Sydney Opera
House is the concert or the Sydney Opera
House it's you know it's it's in
prestige you know it's not the biggest
venue it's not even probably the best
venue to play but it's in prestige wise
it's like you know it's a big deal and
so we were taping two shows that night
for the special right and the idea is
like you know the first one was packed
full the second one was pretty much full
but like the idea was you know you do
the first show you get that and then you
know just anything you didn't get right
in the first show you've got the second
show to make sure that yeah yeah you get
that right or whatever you know that's
the model so I I do the first show but
what I've done on this night is I've
forgotten because it's like a night
we're taping it and I've got to get
makeup and hair and blah blah blah I
just when I did the first like the first
show was technically very confident I
hid all the jokes and if that's if we
only taped one show then you would have
used the first show and you would have
been happy with how the stretch away but
because they had it in the can what I
then did was like ah [ __ ] it
alright I'm going to have some beers we
may have gone outside come back inside
and then I just loved the second shot
because it felt like what it is actually
like if you came to see me do a night of
stand-up comedy that's what it's going
to look like more than the first one
which was more technically proficient
like there's a whole improv bit in the
special like because of the second show
and I just like found myself in a weed
hole in a bit I've done like a thousand
times but that night it just came out
different and I can't in the special
I've never told that joke that way any
other time but it's the recorded version
that people will go oh well I guess that
was a version of the joke it's not at
all but I just loved that show and I
didn't think I look too [ __ ] up like
like we released it with this
essentially the whole show is just that
second show like you know we barely I
think used anything at all from the
first show in the in the show my hair is
a little sloppier you know in the first
show it doesn't need mini ice in the
second show it kind of flops out and and
and I'm definitely looser but I was like
people
I think I'm [ __ ] up and then every now
and again I just get a message from
someone online God how [ __ ] up were
you doing that sure and I'm like oh I I
could in my head I'm like Nana I'm fine
yeah I can tell
and then occasionally someone can tell
and I'm like eh I went when I was young
we did this thing called premium blend
and there was a comic there who was like
I need a beer by the way I probably the
very first I've ever did stand-up I was
going out to have a drink and this guy
Kristian harloff said to me it isn't
Tallahassee and I went to get a beer and
he goes amen
nothing or nothing that's a really bad
habit to start right now and he goes
because if you need that to get on
tonight you'll always need it so do it
sober do you like it so I did it totally
sober and then and then I would have
beers sometimes but not really wasn't
something I needed but then we did this
taping and I watched this comic and they
wouldn't allow him to have a drink on
stage and he didn't know to what to do
with his hand bright because he'd always
had a beer in his hand and his and it
was I was like oh [ __ ]
and he was so uncomfortable I was like
oh I'm never gonna let that happen and
so I've always tried to work like I'll
bring a drink on stage of me but very
seldomly do I touch it and but a little
delay chose when I start telling the
Machine story I go alright I'm gonna
murder this drink and get through this
story oh yeah I I was just doing just
laughing Montreal and one of the things
that I just might set at the gala I just
did too fast it's a mistake that I can
sometimes make when I'm just not quite
on it or it's like that or whatever is
like I can speed up and really the trick
is to slow down yeah but what I realized
was part of it was environmental because
my classic slow down move is to just
lean back to that stool because I always
have the stool literally just basically
right next to me and we'll have a drink
there right yeah and I can just either
lean on the stool or just like touch my
drink or just like go to grab my drink
or have a drink or whatever and that'll
slow me but when I was out there and I
was already at this pace that I
shouldn't have been at you know I just a
little bit you know bigger than I needed
to be I had nothing I had no brakes like
you know I just couldn't find a
mechanism like a different physical
thing where I could just go this steps
me
out of it and gives me a little bright
which going and getting a drink or
having a super like doing whatever you
can just break and you can reset a
little oh that's what they just we
haven't talked about touring and about
my special - no special in February and
my agents are like hey come do it at the
Trocadero they're like you probably
should do some similar rooms and right
because there is a pacing like when you
go into a theater it's just pitch black
you're like oh now I'm just monologuing
like I'm not really connecting with
anyone I'm monologuing you're like oh
yeah I should probably do some of those
so get the rhythm like I'm yeah well
that's not that's not thing to do about
doing a big shot like if you do the
opera house it's hard to say hey can I
come and do four nights of the house
before I do if they're a similar room
like this at Des Moines yeah you guys
yeah if they're yeah yeah can i play the
waka waka Opera House yes area no I I uh
I love clubs I did my last special to
club and I was going to do this one in
his club but uh but yeah I think the
next one I do I might go back and do it
like a club show I you know I quite like
the idea of doing some big ones for a
while but I I feel like I wouldn't mind
shooting a little like cuz I actually
think when you watched them like a club
show feels you can actually get more
into the rhythm because the thing about
watching stand-up on DVD or whatever
because a lot of people do it these days
so you just got to acknowledge that they
do is that you're very disconnected from
the experience that the audience is
having them in the room yeah and I think
sometimes in the really big shows you
just get completely disconnected whereas
in the smaller shows the club shows like
a lot of Stanhope stuff for example he
always his stuff so it's film you know
pretty acting like small venues and you
can actually sort of get in the rhythm
of going I can almost feel like I'm here
I could almost be leaning at the bar at
the back of this show you know yeah I
feel like that too but you know the
buyers just part of the reason I'm doing
Australia is that you want to show the
buyer oh I can play to an international
market so that they go oh we can you
know but then they go because what their
parameters are there like big theatres I
want to show that we have stars here and
part of me is like nah like my favorite
the Louis specials want to get at the
store like that was just intimate I love
that [ __ ] but yeah I mean there's a
difference obviously you know and
because this is
the funny thing about it we started
talking before about that idea of like
just pursuing what it is that you
artistically want to do but of course
you are also in like show business and
like half of that word is business and
so there is a part of it that you're
like well I'd like to be able to do
whatever the [ __ ] I like to do I don't
die negative luck in mirrors but
business like we're talking about like
right now I'm doing clubs I'm doing 450
Cedars in most 400 cedar clubs selling
out six shows a weekend and making
really good money and they're like in
order to take a step forward you need to
take two steps back you need to do
thousand Cedars like Club theaters
you're going to make a quarter of the
money but it'll look good to everybody
industry and then we can sell your story
I'm like [ __ ] that the story is I'd
rather make I'd rather make you know X
amount of dollars in a club and walk
away and buy a [ __ ] pool right and
take cash for it then do a theater like
who are we doing this for like you know
other business do you take a step back
to like like no relation they're like so
I know this really sucks going really
good but we're gonna start doing
threesomes trust me it'll be better for
us in the long run you're like no it's
not well the most accessible saves
inertia is like profitable sales in
shows I've ever done in my entire life
and just a great example of what you're
talking about
because I mean like enough at home I
have like you know a melon company
festival you know play twenty one twenty
two shows in a thousand seats theater
like you know a lot of people come and
see shows right but you know you also
have to hire a thousand seat theater and
all the people that come with a sales
and steepy really are the exact same
amount of people you have to hire in a
thousand seat theater then you do for a
six thousand CPC the theater there's no
difference in what it costs to operate a
theater two thousand versus operating
theater at six thousand the goal is to
put you in a six thousand seater where
you're walking with 150 grand but in
order to walk 150 grand you got to walk
with ten when you can make 50 so best
thing I ever did and the most enjoyable
run of shows I ever did most profitable
I ever did and the reason I'm telling
you this story is because it's so
nonsensical that I've never done it
again it's an exact example of what
you're talking about which is the idea
of like for some reason when I film the
special or you know you do these other
things you go I'm going to do
the Opera House I've seen none of that
money by the time we film the [ __ ]
special and we pay the [ __ ] Opera
House and blah blah blah blah blah
you're like I did all this work and like
failed in two people came and everyone
got paid but me yeah you know like I
just want to get paid from this house
it's impossible yeah right yeah but I
did this runner shows the Sydney Comedy
Store
I was in Sydney and I was the day you
have their regular show at 8:30 yeah and
I was like hey can I just come down and
do my show at 7:00 they don't normally
have anything on at 7:00 I was like I
just want to I just want to come down
and do the shot seven I'll be done by
like 8:05 you know you can roll in your
other crowd and back then they were also
at a point in their evolution where I
was like and you know what if people
having a good night I'll just go tell
them to stick around and it was a few
nights early on legally in the mid weeks
wherefore then having like another 40 or
50 people who might roll into the the
actual main show of the night was like
cool for them as well so I ended up like
I was like I think I was going to do
four weeks at the start like a nice
think I'm miles doing like Tuesday
through Saturday or whatever I was doing
but it just kept selling because all I
had to sell every night was 280 tickets
like you know so like you're not really
like and it would just we weren't
advertising it I don't do a radio or
whatever but like you know I mean it
just would sell because people would
come along and have a good time yeah and
they would tell other people to come and
so we just get doing it and I end up
doing like 10 weeks or something
ridiculous of this show but it was the
best job of all time because I would get
up like in the day I'd do whatever else
I had to achieve I go down there at 7:00
I'd be done at 8:05 like I'd be home at
like 825 oh my god
but it was like a it was like a day job
yeah it was like being able to do my
show I guess it was like the equivalent
of like if you are in Broadway or if
you're on blah blah where you could just
go or Vegas yeah well you're like oh
well this is my job every night at this
time and then I do my show but other
than that I can just get online laughs
and it was the best I'm doing I did it
again burn I'm doing Denver in a couple
weeks and then I look I don't know how
it went down I'll just tell you my from
what I heard they were like she doesn't
think you can sell a weekend and I was
like in my head I was like I can
definitely sell a weekend but when I
rest mine just give me an off night like
she'll give you Sunday night so Sunday
nights sold out in like 30 minutes and
they're like yeah you want to do another
Sunday show I go yeah so we have another
funny show that sells out there like you
Monday show I go yeah hey you wanna do
another Monday show I go yeah like hey
do you wanna do Tuesday and in my head I
go yeah just bug me Tuesday Wednesday
and it'll stick around first and hope on
Thursday and then see what she's got the
next weekend I'll do Friday Saturday
Sunday if she wants to and it's the best
money I'll ever make right the most fun
will have because it's just Monday just
walking down to the club doing a show
right off the [ __ ] bass and in Denver
yeah I can't [ __ ] wait but like these
like the shows this trusty oddities like
three show [ __ ] that's all right no it's
the beauty of podcast it's up if he
shows on Saturday when you do three
shows on Saturday those stress me out
I'm like all right like I would love to
find a place where you just do one hour
every single night yeah oh well that's
the sacred so that was the great joy
they show so it's just the hour it's not
doubles on Fridays or Saturday's or
triples or whatever it is that takes all
the joy out of it it's just doing is
showing people the [ __ ] you out of it
my Thursday's or my favorite shows ever
because I go in and I it's just one show
I usually be like an hour 40 just one
show and I'm like I'm [ __ ] around I'm
writing onstage I'm taking old stories
and and doing like best Stubbs for
people because I thought a lot of times
with storytellers people want to hear
stories they've heard before right you
know they're like like and so I don't
mind that if it's a Thursday showing on
the second show I'll tell them but uh
but yeah I love a one show I want to do
that I want to just move like what the
[ __ ] am I doing in LA I should just move
to a town oh I would love a residency in
Vegas right love residency in Vegas
Ralphie Matt you know Ralphie May yeah
Ralphie May get off her residency in
Vegas like I don't know if I should take
it my go are you kidding me you're in
Vegas you could get a trainer you could
you can live a life and then just go to
stand up at night right what's a night
once a night yeah at the same place at
the same place essentially you just have
a job that goes for an hour
oh you walk in you like and they know
what you want you're like salmon
broccoli rabe they got it ready for you
that's where you eat your dinner they
got a double Tito's and total waiting
for you at the end of the show you got
you can have your own we don't so travel
with it you just take a bong hit this is
done I'm [ __ ] into a residency all
right well let's hope you get one out of
this podcast big Vegas listenership
so can I ask you this tell us about well
I mean this podcast also is listening to
buy a whole bunch of American people so
anything you want to plug but
particularly let's talk about the fact
that you're coming down in Australia so
September do you know your dates or
where do they find them where's the best
place for them to go to find information
about thinking go to Bert Bert Bert Bert
comp I'll tell you right now
Perth I'm in Singapore the 9th Perth the
11th Sydney the 13th ok Melbourne the
Fort do you have the venue's it yeah
yeah but no no oh yeah yeah actually I
can tell you might tell me where you are
by the way I tell you where I am and
I'll tell you how many people tickets
are sold
ok this would be good then we can say
the bump when the podcast comes out we
can do a very accurate bump of people
coming out to see the show all right all
right here we go here we go these are
good
um I'm at the soda theatre in Singapore
okay it seats 600 hell yeah I've sold
158 all right you know what I've heard
about Singapore like buyers that's good
I reckon I'd like 125 if you're curious
that's 26 percent of the I don't think
that's too bad actually still a month
away right that's that's a guy I think
this is that Singapore's was gonna write
to me I feel I feel good about yeah
octagon a Theatre in Perth is seat 680
I'm a 580 that was going to sell out
back yeah he's also going to be a really
really fun show so beautiful that is one
of my favorite venues in Australia to
perform at the octagon theatre yeah it's
it's at a university it's it genuinely
is kind of an octagon shape seeing like
the audience are in a lake but it's just
it yeah you'll get to have a really good
time there get tickets without it
there's only a few left to that one so
thank you for sellout Sydney is I'm at
the m-more ah beautiful hi hey we guys
beautiful day 1,500 were eight hundred
so it's over half sold but that'll
probably sell I reckon that's going to
sell out as well yes it oh man saw that
mo this is that you know the Rolling
Stones later they're more this is like
oh yeah this was like look you look at
the posters on the wall I've seen a heap
of the best gigs I've ever seen in my
life at the
well that would be great you know that's
over half sold so that I usually I can
tell if I can get a half a month out
usually it picks up on Melbourne I'm at
the comedy theater
Oh see silent this is where that what
does it say tell me six nine nine fifty
right okay 950 that's what that's the
one I play during the comedy the comedy
theater you like that - that's a real
fun theater that's a seven twenty
that'll sell out I think yeah and then I
reopened we're in the tiboli that seats
650 were at the 580 such it's gonna sell
it - yeah all right
um Sydney's the big boy sub be cool I've
never I've never performed by myself for
1500 the molle like meaning like I
booked them right none the most I've
ever did was the Wilbur seats twelve and
uh and and we know month out we were at
50% and it and it sold out and that was
one of the most amazing shows I ever had
well I'm gonna say I've got a pretty
good feeling about this something like
that Sydney and more show again again if
you're in Sydney go out and see it
because I reckon that may well be the
big one for you I reckon you're gonna
get over those numbers so yeah that'll
be exciting right I would really love
that that would be maybe a fun show to
be at as well just like I think it's fun
to be at those shows for comedians as
well like you know if you're at
something where for them it's a bit of a
big deal and especially you know I made
a big mistake at embossed in at the lobe
er um I'd never performed in anything
that big that I had sold tickets to me
meeting me and I was like I gotta see
what it's like to look from the top you
know so I got up in the top of the club
and I was like maybe I'll grab a beer
you know come a beer up here bring it on
stage and I go and I didn't realize
there's 1,200 that want to see me so as
soon as I show up everyone [ __ ] loses
their [ __ ] like right like oh but the
[ __ ] you doing up here and then I was
like and I ruined the poor guy on stage
there was a huge because I didn't
realise that they're there to see me it
was like so often you're so used to not
just people being in the club and get
through we can do y'all do it and then
just I got the back and ever once so
that was crazy that Emma will be a big
deal for me
well it's a very exciting venue and they
brilliant crude there at the end Moto's
I'll look after you you'll have a
genuinely good time with that
mate you said normally when you do one
show and and either goes for an hour or
40 and we have pretty much got to an
hour and 40 so I think that's pretty
good to me last what are you gonna do my
podcast well it's called the dirt cast
right and people can find that wing the
places that they find podcast but yeah
we'll do that for sure please yeah
please yeah we're definitely does some
Foster's that's a big what's the view
you guys have an Australian well you
know the funding is that in Australia we
don't have sponsors like it's it's an
imported beer to see that we sell to the
world but that no one in Australia
drinks what's the one you guys drink I
had all sorts of different one was Italy
were you you're in Sydney so maybe to
ease Cooper's no venom
it was been well you've gotta have money
you gonna have your my podcast but yes I
was gonna say I was going to say about
the Fosters though that guarantee a
Garrett Reynolds do Genesis so the other
night he came over to do the podcast and
he brought me as a joke could like a
giant can of fosters and then the other
night when I had run air beer and I was
looking at a gun all right I'm gonna
drip drink a giant can of Buster's like
you know what I'm an Australian I
believe I can did it and I got to be
honest with ya I quite enjoyed it then
you went on your balcony I have a
cigarette there's a black guy next to me
so you know something oldie and you guys
let me tell you like ass we like you
know what sometimes scary Oh judge this
very a judge you know well it's been a
pleasure to have y'all you might thank
you very much thank you will
[Music]